hi everyone welcome to another unboxing
today we have nothing so today we are
unboxing the Mario Plus rabbits kingdom
battle collector's edition I am here
with my good friend Jake was going to
describe exactly what goes in or what is
in this collector's edition at the very
least you can see the rabbit Mario
rabbit in the front but we have a couple
of other things in here too which you
can describe while I shred this box all
right let's do it
[Music]
yeah you guys gotta shred it oh my gosh
don't you shouldn't have send help Oh
Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey right here this
guy doesn't how to treat a box properly
yeah so this is one of those annoying
sleeve things though right yeah I mean
people don't really keep these anyway
these are kind of pointless what you
really want is this one right here so
I'm gonna I'm gonna so unlike some of
the other collector's editions that we
have unbox this one actually comes with
the game so there's that one right there
apparently it's the it's a special
edition of the game I'm not sure if it
comes with any additional DLC it says it
includes pixel pack with eight unique
weapon in school
inside we also have the official
soundtrack of the game which was
composed by the great grant kirkhope and
right here we have a pack of collector's
collector cards no no no trading cards
you're supposed to trade them with with
other money all that have is as well and
here's the meat of the collector's
edition right here will statue got the
the Mario rabid Oh more things to cut
Hey
grab that guy he's fine we'll peg the
stand on you know what actually this
thing is pretty well well-built it's got
a nice weight to it so what do we have
here you know just a gummy we have some
ice cream right there or something
should we open up the cards yes let's
open up the cards and trade them with no
one I hear what we're gonna do we just
get six and we get to trade with each
other
oh this 12 minute there's 12 in there
we're not gonna look Joey wait
I need the box I got it I got it I got
it I got it
oh there's shinies there Shane wall man
so I've got a rabid Kong here when my
Chinese is the Bowser jr. card phantom
and then you don't care about the rest
because they're not shiny now this one
got the per rabbit plant
finally we do have the soundtrack and
thankfully we actually have something to
play this compact disc on I don't know
it's heavy though
well it didn't i second this we're going
to I like this one
Joey you said you've been working on
some dance moves for this soundtrack no
alright then lick it Joey
Mike wants you to lick it yeah actually
I did it like I never did either but I'm
not gonna lick it after you like it okay
no that's bad
alright now I have to try and try the
other side that's why I'm gonna do the
other side oh yeah I'm putting that back
in by the way
wet dry for whoever wants it next
alright and that was everything that was
in the Mario Plus rabbits kingdom battle
collector's edition up the game statue
cards soundtrack wolf by the way I just
heard if this is sold out so you won't
be able to get it in stores but you can
always check eBay try to look there so
stay tuned for our review of the game
and
[Music]